et
[Musique]
je soussigné lucien morel conseiller
municipal informe que ses feux dans les
tons fille ciel informe que les missions
des shadoks et son auteur doivent être
internés parmi les faibles d'esprit
une autre lettre maintenant texte là au
siècle nous sommes cette émission
conviendrait mieux à des débiles mentaux
voilà mon opinion de médecin je suis
attardé mental
ma femme est des vies des enfants sont
de vraies mais on n est évidemment
nombreux sont ceux qui réclament autre
chose et cette lettre en est un exemple
je voulais lui donnez nous des émissions
éducatives plutôt que ces folies nous
voulons des jeux des concours instructif
[Musique]
m
répondre
combien
de page d'accueil
yahoo
la chlamydia
les marins refuse de participer à des
émissions complètement absurde ouais
remanier la maison ce qui est encore
plus pénible c'est de voir qu'avec notre
argent on paie grassement les employés
pour qu'ils ne nous donne pas
satisfaction un vrai patron n'accepterai
pas ça et c'est vrai dans toutes les
lettres les gens disent nous payons
notre redevance par conséquent nous
sommes les patrons des gens qui sont à
l'horaire tf
nous avons 40 millions de patron
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tha
[Musique]
à
et ça
mais bon
hier
[Musique]
you
ceci se passe de commentaires nous avons
quand même des lettres pauvre monsieur
je suis partisan du maintien de
l'émission des shadoks pour les motifs
suivants en raison de ses autres
qualités esthétiques intellectuelle et
morale et parce que son interprète à la
même voie que celle de mon curé et que
je prends désormais un intérêt accru aux
sermons dominicaux signée jean calinaud
avec ad c'est un laïc doit
wall et amen est une chose là pour le
mécontenter personne
[Musique]